la première fois que j'ai vécu une
révolution j'avais 7 ans c'est lorsqu'on
m'a offert cet appareil un ordinateur
to7 de la marque thomson
alors comme vous je savais pas trop à
quoi ça pouvait servir à cette époque là
mais bizarrement j'ai eu aucun problème
pour me l'approprier je vais vous donner
la recette comment j'ai fait c'est assez
simple
j'ai d'abord appuyé sur le bouton j'ai
utilisé l'appareil alors faut être très
france j'étais très fort sur le numéro 3
a réglé le crayon optique c'est est ce
qu'il va être plus facile et en fait
quand on comprend pas une technologie
faut faire toujours ce qu'il ya de plus
simple
rapidement j'ai commencé à apprendre à
me familiariser avec cette de ce bel
outil
et puis j'ai commencé à le comprendre à
voir comment il fonctionne et est donc
j'ai commencé à interagir avec la
machine puis là je ne suis pas resté là
j'ai bien entendu voulu l'améliorer à
cette époque là on pouvait commander un
clavier ça faisait chose un petit peu
plus ordinateur c'était un peu le côté
culturel de tout ça et c'est devenu le
to7 70 et puis bien sûr ce qui m'a
beaucoup passionné aussi c'est que j'ai
commencé à contribuer donc fabriquer mes
propres jeux ou participer avec des jeux
de mes copains qu'on se partage et à la
cour d'école sur des disquettes
voilà donc pourquoi c'était une
révolution tout ça c'est que pour la
première fois j'ai compris ce qu'était
la liberté et qui formera finalement un
socle de la culture tout au long de ma
vie et la liberté c'est avant tout la
possibilité d'utiliser ces la
possibilité de modifier c'est la
possibilité de distribuer et c'est
surtout la possibilité de comprendre
alors on peut pas parler technologie
sans les légendes et les mythes qui vont
avec puisqu'une technologie commence à
devenir évidente pour tout le monde à
partir du moment évidemment on a des
mythes et des légendes et moi j'ai
découvert wargame comme certains ici
c'est là que j'ai découvert le hacking
où ce jeune débouler sur le réseau
arpanet est en fait allé se connecter un
jeu et en croyant jouer en fait tilt en
train déclenché une guerre
thermonucléaire effets magnifique et
puis paradoxalement la même personne qui
m'avait faire l'ordinateur peut-être que
c'est un signe m'emmener à notre voir un
autre film qui s'appelait 2001 l'odyssée
de l'espace de stanley kubrick est là en
fait c'est un ordinateur hal qui
commence à prendre le contrôle du
vaisseau donc voilà ça fait un petit peu
peur évidemment on ne freinaient un peu
je connaissais pas la technologie encore
que déjà on m'avait mis des freins
alors en fait ce qui s'est passé à ce
moment là c'est que je suis simplement
d'une génération où on a mis la
technologie tout en haut de la pyramide
cette technologie nous a donné des
légendes et des mythes et puis tout ça
ça fait ma culture et j'ai cru pendant
longtemps que l'évolution c'était la
technologie et peut-être comme certains
dans la salle
alors voilà à peu près à l'effet que ça
m'a fait un je vous rassure la techno le
geek est tous et où c'est vite passé à
côté
et puis comme on nous l'a dit à
l'accueil effectivement ans vivait nos
crises à notre manière le chômage des
problèmes dans le monde et c'est alors
tout ça ça s'est très bien déroulé
jusqu'à peu près en 2004 en fait allez
savoir mais la naissance peut-être de
mon deuxième enfant
j'ai pris comme beaucoup ici conscience
que le monde allait pas très bien et
j'ai voulu faire des choses j'ai voulu
m'engager alors dans des associations
dans des collectifs ou des choses comme
ça et puis bien entendu en mettant le
numérique ma culture dit que je n'allais
quand même pas renier au coeur de tout
ça je me suis dit c'est quand même
bizarre ce numérique on peut faire plein
de choses je pense que jaurès diderot
d'alembert aurait utilisé ses
technologies dans leurs oeuvres et
aujourd'hui non la photo vous voyez au
milieu a été prise et à peu près quatre
ans dans une bibliothèque en france par
une amie donc voilà le niveau qu'on
considérait sur le numérique
donc évidemment je me suis intéressé à
plat de sujets les problèmes
d'inondation les problèmes d'eau
problème d'empreinte écologique
certains ont déjà entendu parler il faut
savoir que avec l'empreinte écologique
en gros quand je me suis intéressé au
sujet vous aviez bouffer la planète au
mois deux mois d'octobre à peu près cet
été vous a fait une rentrée on la mange
et le 19 août tout ça pour vous dire
qu'en fait je me suis engagé dans plein
de choses comme vous j'avais plus de
famille j'avais plus d'amis j'avais plus
rien j'étais tout le temps tout le temps
dans des associations des collectifs des
choses comme ça et puis à côté de saab
j'ai allumé la télé j'ai allumé la radio
et les choses ne s'amélioraient pas
alors ça c'était un peu ma méthode pour
connaître faut toujours être un poteau
critique pourquoi ça marche pas
effectivement j'avais ce tempérament
tête de forains puisque mon père était
forain donc j'ai effectivement cette
aventure des marchés beaucoup de
confiance en moi
effectivement ça me paraissait évident
donc j'avais une méthode un peu de
passage en force
et puis bien sûr je suis de la
génération internet donc il ya des
choses qu'on fait dans sa rue il ya des
choses qu'on fait dans son immeuble puis
à les choses convient aussi en ligne et
moi je n'arrêtais pas de faire des lots
des yo-yo donc en fait un chemin des 6es
beaucoup en ligne et puis évidemment mes
copains en bas me disais ouais mais tu
es trop haut perchée et air-sol
bon alors je venais dans le terrain qui
apprend le 10e homme était trop boueuse
était trop terre à terre et j'arrêtais
pas de faire cet aller retour
et en fait j'ai compris une chose c'est
qu'on avait un vrai vrai vrai problème
essentiel la confiance
nous sommes actuellement dans une
société qui ne se fait plus confiance
et encore quand ce fait confiance si
vous arrivez à trouver de la confiance
il y aura un autre problème c'est la
bienveillance faut que ça dure dans le
temps la confiance et il s'avère que
quand vous faites ces allers retours
entre leur sol aient une vie vaut la
derrière vous forcément il ya des choses
qui se désagrège et c'est peut-être pour
ça je ne veux faire aucune conclusion
mais c'est peut-être pour ça que notre
monde associatif se porte si mal
c'est pour ça que l'économie sociale et
solidaire dit beaucoup de choses mais
elle peine encore à créer des emplois
elle peine encore à créer les choses qui
vont mal dans le monde etc etc alors à
ce moment là on pourrait se dire bon
rôle est rentré chez lui il arrêter non
non non pas du tout j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à ce qu'on voyait justement
entre le hors ligne et le en ligne et là
j'ai commencé à entendre parler des
tiers lieux alors d'abord par un
sociologue qui avait créé quelque chose
pour starbucks café il y avait besoin de
faire une étude et puis ces sociologues
expliqué qu'ils avaient des tiers
espaces alors moi ce que j'ai surtout
compris à ce moment là c'est très simple
c'est qu'en fait contrairement à ce
qu'on m'avait éduquer là en fait la
technologie romney à sa vraie place un
outil et que c'est simplement les gens
qui poussaient des cultures et qui
poussaient des mythes très important
alors qu'est ce que c'est qu'un tiers
lieu parce que moi évidemment je
pourrais vous en parler des heures je
suis devenu passionné je suis tombé dans
le chaudron comme obélix attire lieu
c'est d'abord quelque chose on vient
travailler pour soi comme ça on n'est
jamais déçu
c'est jamais un lieu qui est trop animés
ou pas assez animé déjà on vient pour
swan ou son ordinateur
est ce assez pour tous ces travailleurs
nomades on est tous de plus en plus à
utiliser des ordinateurs et puis on ou
son ordinateur on se connecte à du wifi
et ça ça donnait à peu le télétravail
rapidement on s'ennuie un peu dans le
télétravail on a voulu travailler aussi
avec d'autres et ça ça donne et le
koweït king mouvement américain kal très
bien arriver en europe
et effectivement on mixe de temps en
temps je travaille seul des fois je
travaille à plusieurs ces gens là
également qui travaille différemment
forcément ils vivent différemment que ce
soit sur les amplitudes horaires leur
mode de consommation au lieu de se
vendre on va se donner on va se prêter
on va se louer et puis bien entendu ces
petits outils qui sont arrivés les
imprimantes 3d vous en avez entendu
parler
alors on n'est pas encore la grande
révolution industrielle jeremy rifkin
mais effectivement commence à voir des
imprimantes 3d dans tous ces tiers lieux
et on peut réparer la télécommande le
bout de plastique a cassé on peut
prototype est un objet qu'on n'a pas une
armoire ikea il nous manque une pièce on
peut la faire donc on vit un petit peu
dit
vraiment et puis surtout ce qui me
passionne dans ses tirs lieu c'est que
ce sont des gens qui entreprennent
autrement mais surtout qui se sont
réapproprié le mot entreprendre qui a
été tant galvaudée pendant longtemps et
qui justement ne plaisait peut-être pas
à le ss à l'éducation populaire que je
vous ai parlé tout à l'heure
revenons sur le mot entreprendre
entreprendre c'est tout simplement faire
à plusieurs c'est faire ensemble que je
sois rénumérés ou pas j'ai entrepris une
oeuvre et ça s'étire lieux ont vraiment
une autre façon d'entreprendre et puis
si ça se travaille et vivre entreprendre
autrement
ben vous ne parlez plus de rôles de
grade 2 je suis chez avis j'ai de
l'argent j'ai pas d'argent mais tout
simplement de rôles et des postures vous
remettez de la poésie et c'est ce que
j'aime beaucoup dans les tiers-lieux
puisqu'on parle de concierge de
veilleuses de jardiniers et ça ça change
beaucoup de choses alors comment j'ai
fait ça cherchez pas un tiers lieux y a
pas besoin de de militantisme ou autre
on le vit c'est point barre il faut
juste vivre un tiers lieux vous venez
une fois vous des deux fois vous envie
visiter un vous en visite et 2 et à ce
moment là vous comprendrez effectivement
ça donne des tirs lieu donc nous on a
fait ça avec le compteur numérique une
bande de crapauds fou à saint-etienne
qui avait simplement envie de mélanger
la médiation numérique avant de les
mélanger le coworking cavernes ville
mélangé les hacker space mais tout
simplement le faire d'une façon
complètement spontanée
donc on a appris en marchant ça a donné
le comptoir derrière on a rencontré
plein de gens donc on s'est donné rendez
vous aux troncs et on a créé une
communauté qui s'est rappelé la
communauté francophone des tirs lieu on
a démarré à 6 on est actuellement un peu
près 1700 1800 francophonie et ça
c'était à peu près trois ans et puis
bien entendu on n'est pas resté lancer
10 quitte à faire un tiers lui rappelez
vous je suis geek
j'ai ma culture geek on s'est dit il
faut le faut partager la recette
donc on a créé une méthodologie movie
lab et puis à ce moment là on a commencé
à documenter tous que nous soyons et
puis très important il faut pas rester
juste derrière son ordinateur rien ne
remplacera une petite bière bue à lille
avec mes amis lillois
rien ne remplacera un petit repas entre
midi et deux et c'est comme ça qu'on va
apprendre justement comment les autres
font leurs tirs lieu donc ça c'est très
important
puis comme chez entrepreneurs j'ai
besoin de travailler donc le matin je
fais du coworking et l'après midi je
fais du slow tourisme c'est à dire que
ce que je vais vivre fera partie
intégrante de mon travail et c'est ça la
magie se laisser aller dans une société
où on contrôle bien sûr un peu tout bien
côté de ça avec quelques amis également
on a décidé d'organiser le premier tour
de france du télétravail et des tiers
lieux peut être un peu respectable de
tout ça et on a fait comme ça à peu près
une vingtaine une trentaine de
deville d'ailleurs en train de faire la
deuxième année de ce tour de france et
c'est assez passionnant puisque on
rencontre des gens relativement brillant
voilà vous savez à peu près tout sur les
tirs lieu ce sont des espaces sont créés
tous les jours des dizaines en bas de
chez vous alors c'est souvent des lieux
qui se revendique tiers-lieux rien de
bâtiments à vous verrez pas des grues
vous verrez pas des ouvriers non
simplement des gens qui font des gens
qui essayent de changer la société
mais qui sont beaucoup moins dans le
dogme ou dans la presse que dans le
faire voilà ils font tout simplement
et puis moi il s'est passé une chose
c'est quelqu'un m'a mis ce bouquin dans
les mains pendant mon voyage pendant que
je faisais du coup aussi au tourisme
il m'a dit à mon avis yoann qui devrait
regarder ça et là effectivement j'ai eu
un gros bouleversement j'arrêtais pas à
chaque fois que je lisais une page de
regarder la page d'accueil la page de
garde en me disant mais c'est nous en
fait j'avais un problème j'ai
l'impression de voir des gens que
j'avais vu à paris à lille etc
alors pourquoi parce qu'en fait dans ces
tirs l'on rencontre des gens fabuleux
on en a parlé un petit peu ce soir sur
steve jobs et c'est qu'il veut changer
la société on se réfère à ceux qui ont
eu des réussites mais effectivement des
steve jobs et des grands inventeurs vous
en voyez tous les jours dans ces tirs
lieu ça s'est relativement passionnant
en termes de technologie même si j'ai
une culture geek vous le savez j'ai
arrêté assez tôt j'ai vu la tête qu'elle
avait 17 ans donc c'était plus vraiment
ça et bien en fait des technologies j'en
côtoie tous les jours quand je travaille
pour moi quand je joue mon ordinateur un
raspberry un arduino je vous rassure moi
n'empêchait pas ce que c'était il ya un
an
aujourd'hui je n'ai maîtrise et tout ça
j'ai pas eu de formation m'a pas formé
autour d'une table j'ai simplement vu
comment il se pratiquait et puis
troisième point de comparaison également
avec ses premiers geeks ces premiers
hackers effectivement les lieux là vous
vous trouvez devant le premier
ordinateur de la société ibm qui
n'auraient jamais pu être une des trois
sociétés mondiales les plus importantes
si pendant la nuit
donc le jour les ingénieurs venait
fabriquer des ordinateurs et la nuit les
hackers les petits jeunes du troisième
en fait monter et corriger les erreurs
des des spécialistes et en fait c'est
tout ça qui a fait que finalement on est
le succès de l'informatique on connaît
également aujourd'hui effectivement
laitière lieu parce que j'ai regardé
c'est très chouette la technologie
qu'ils ont sortis mais finalement c'est
peut-être le garage dans lesquelles ils
ont fabriqué ces technologies qu'on
aurait dû se fixer à l'époque up
alors je suis persuadé qu'il ya plein de
gens qui doutent mais voilà vous êtes
déjà dans une société 2.0
allez allez dans votre poche vous pouvez
smartphones aux ordinateurs et vous ayez
20 ans que vous ayez 80 ans
ma grand-mère à la également aujourd'hui
facebook et twitter n'y a pas de
problème à la 80 ans mais voilà à peu
près ce que ça a donné
alors pourquoi vous avez cette société
2.0 dans votre poche parce qu'on a fait
des choix la simplicité le design est
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas une entreprise
une structure qui ne travaille pas
aujourd'hui avec un ordinateur
et puis pareil le fait d'avoir développé
cette technologie n'a pas empêché
développer des nouvelles activités
professionnelles à ma connaissance tout
le monde utilise ce genre de dothy par
contre moi ya une chose qui m'a qui m'a
beaucoup plu mais c'est le petit
troisième celui qu'on parle un peu moins
qui pourtant est libre c'est le fameux
sous linux et ici personne n'utilise
nous linux non vous n'utilisez pas à
genoux linux vous utilisez une
distribution et c'est ça qui est
fabuleux ses terres qu'il ya un capital
informationnel commun à l'intérieur de
ce logiciel qui appartient à tout le
monde et à partir de ce capital
informationnel commun vous allez pouvoir
fabriquer votre distribution qui l'a
s'appellera ubuntu fedora mind là vous
utilisez ces choses là mais nous linux
n'est simplement qu'un patrimoine
informationnel commun et les avantages
qu'on a quand on travaille sur du
patrimoine informationnel commun c'est
qu'on sait pas que de la technologie on
permet également d'influencé de grandes
choses de grands mouvements et en
l'occurrence wikipédia moi
personnellement je pourrais pas passer
de wikipédia openstreetmap le projet de
cartographie libre je ne pourrais pas me
passer de bonnes frites map voilà
l'avantagé également du lit par rapport
aux propriétaires il est peut-être des
fois moins simple il est peut-être des
fois moins design en l'occurrence il
vous permet de faire beaucoup plus de
choses
alors voilà ça mais paraît évident alors
ça c'est moins lieu il ya un an et demi
deux ans j'arrive plus à dormir je suis
persuadé que nous avons inventé
l'ordinateur du 21e siècle et
qu'aujourd'hui si on compare nos
tiers-lieux ce sont bien des lieux des
espaces ils sont tous différents comme
aux ordinateurs est ce que tu as fait
est ce que tu as à ibm est ce que tu
vois votre coquille elle est toute
différente à l'intérieur et un système
d'exploitation vous avez choisi le
simple design libre en tout cas il ya un
système d'exploitation c'est un langage
qui permet à la machine de tourner
ensuite vous avez des logiciels pourquoi
pas réfléchir aujourd'hui disco soupe
oui chers maixent tous ces mouvements
qui fonctionne très bien aujourd'hui qui
dans le hors sol aujourd'hui emmène des
tas de gens oui cher vous imaginez un an
46 pays communautés que qui ont été
réunis dans le monde en un an sur la
conso collab et 6 ans le réfléchissant
logiciels et qu'on le mettait dans nos
tiers-lieux on aurait beaucoup moins
besoin de ses vergers lisais beaucoup
moins de parler on pourrait agir et
enfin le dernier point bien entendu les
groupes les groupes d'utilisateurs comme
ceux qui en mai améliorer le
linux de l'époque voilà ça fait toujours
très court pour parler d'une passion et
si des gens ici pense que je ne suis pas
concret alors on va être très concret
pour juste finir la concrétude cette
année à malkin ou souffrance moque on
souffre tous en ce moment dès que vous
dit quelque chose d'un peu différent à
s'il te plaît soyons concret je trouve
c'est vraiment une injure parce que la
concrétude pour un chômeur masse et
toucher son salaire à la fin du mois
pour quelqu'un qui est dans la rue c'est
de pouvoir dormir pour un grand patron
c'est peut-être d'éviter de qui avait
dix mille personnes qui se retrouve au
chômage tout le monde a une façon d'être
concret alors si vous voulez qu'on soit
concret ça va être assez simple nous
aujourd'hui les tirs lieu je vous dise
en craie de partout tous les jours en
bas de chez nous et c'est des jeunes des
vieux des des gens qui travaillent des
gens qui recherchent a créé une
entreprise qui les créent donc ils n'ont
pas besoin de venir faire des tedx par
contre il a envie de vous aidez nous
aidez globalement il aimerait tout
simplement que ben ce qu'ils font
travailler vivre entreprendre autrement
bah ils puissent le partager comme un
réseau internet avec d'autres parce que
chacun va se spécialiser quand même dans
une particularité il y en a qui sont
très bons dans ces tiers lieu au niveau
de la mobilité ils ont réfléchi sur les
nouvelles façons de se prêter des vélos
de se prêter des voitures ou de les
louer entre particuliers
d'autres vont être très bon sur
l'éducation d'autres voies très bon sur
l'emploi tout va dépendre est tout
simplement on aimerait bien aujourd'hui
on a une envie de les connecter ensemble
et pour ça bien entendu il faut que ces
tirs lieu est un patrimoine
informationnel commun est comme ça aussi
c'est très français on veut y mettre des
labels
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui nous le
demandons du libre et de l'open source
et surtout pas des labels puisque depuis
des années on nous colle des labels
récemment french tech
récemment les fab lab va là où il y
avait de la coopération barroso c'est la
belle on nous a mis de la compétition et
du coup ça marche plus derrière
donc voilà nous avons une envie c'est
celle de nous connecter le besoin c'est
celle de fabrique un patrimoine
informationnel commun et puis bien
entendu là je fais appel à tous les
designers si vous n'êtes pas
complètement convaincu que nous avons
inventé l'ordinateur du 21e siècle
venez nous aider parce que je pense
qu'il restera plus qu'à faire une petite
interface design et puis à ce moment là
les tirs lieu ben faites les vous mêmes
merci